( man )
She witnessed the
whole thing.
She is the key to
solving this murder.
Okay, so what is it you
actually need from me?
She has multiple-personality
disorder.
The one that saw the
murder is named Kimberly.
We need you to bring
out that personality.
See what I can do.
Hi there,
I'm Dr. Morgan.
( with accent)
Hi.
I'm from the South.
Would you like
some lemonade?
That's a southern
accent?
I would love
some lemonade.
What's your name?
( with accent )
My name?
Yes, I bet a beautiful
southern belle
has a beautiful
southern name.
I'm not from
the South.
I'm from London,
my name Will.
She sounds like a
God-damn chimney sweep.
Is this a
different person?
You sound kind of...
like the other girl.
( with accent )
What'cha mean?
A second ago I was talking
to somebody from the South,
but you're
from London.
( Childlike )
I'm this many
years old.
My name's Katrina.
I got one that age.
Doesn't this bother
you a little bit?
Doesn't this upset
you at all?
Okay, good, now
we're getting somewhere.
Hi... Katrina.
Can you tell me
if Kimberly can
come out and talk?
I'm Melinda.
I'm the sexy one.
Excuse me
a minute.
She's mocking
us, right?
No, she's not.
You know those
people who are
just really terrible
at doing accents?
Yeah.
Well, she's one
of those people.
Unfortunately, she
happens to have
a multiple-personality
disorder.
For Christ's sakes.
Fascinating,
she actually believes
she's these
different people.
She just doesn't have
the faculties
to create the dialect.
So you're saying
that she...
She sucks at having
multiple personalities.
( with accent )
Get me out of here!
What is that now?
Is that an Asian?
Jamaican,
I don't know.
Look, whoever you are,
we really need to talk
to Kimberly, please.
Who?
Is this Kimberly?
Yes?
Kimberly, what did
you see last night?
I...
"sawr a moon
wid da goon."
Oh, what is
she saying?
She's worse at doing
accents than I thought.
Can you...
slow down
when you talk?
I...
sawrs...
a moon...
wid da goon.
Is that the Swedish chef,
what is it, come on.
No Swedish chef, you can
sometimes hear what he's saying.
Can we please just go round
up a bunch of black guys?
Yeah, let's do that.
( with accent )
Hello?